you mentioned to me that since October
7th a lot of young people in the United
States and in general have been showing
interest in
Islam first of all can you explain what
you've been seeing and experiencing uh
in terms of that Trend yeah we have
Quran Tik Tok Trends uh where you had a
few people that went on camera and said
you know I'm reading the Quran for the
first time and I think that
that's the beauty of the faith of the
people of Gaza the beauty of their
resilience you know when you're looking
at these people living what's hell on
Earth but they're seeking Paradise
outside and they're able to still be
inspired towards words of of faith and
determination and certainty you're like
what is their secret right what are they
reading what are they on that allows
them uh to still face this brutality
with such Grace right I mean they're not
shouting profanities they're not not
shouting um you know words of emptiness
or despair but rather they are pouring
out their hearts that are full of faith
for the world to see and I think that a
lot of people have seen that and said
what is that and so um you know we've
had multiple people come to the mosque
I've never seen more people um become
Muslim in my life but not just that but
gain an appreciation for Islam like what
type of an engineering is there you know
that that allows for people to have that
type of Faith uh so people are opening
the Quran for the first time people are
asking questions about Islam in a way
that shows that they're inspired uh even
though they're heartbroken by what
they're seeing what's a good way to get
introduced to Islam the the faith the
the spiritual experience of it well I
think look you go to uh you know our web
we sites you go to whyislam.org you go
to you come to yakin's website y.org you
go to multiple Islamic
websites to get those questions answered
but there's nothing like going to a
mosque there's nothing like actually
going to a mosque and meeting Muslims
and asking
questions and I tell people like you
have to step out of your comfort zone
and go there and let your world be
complicated a bit
experience it listen to the sermon meet
people from different backgrounds and
ask questions Muslims love to be asked
by the way about their faith because
they're so sick of hearing other people
talk about it so Muslims love to be
asked about their faith Palestinians
love to be asked about Palestine because
they're so sick of other people talking
about it so uh ask questions and uh you
will have them answered but there's
nothing like a physical connection
there's nothing like a human connection
so uh definitely try to reach out to
your local Islamic organizations and
meet people how difficult is it to
convert to Islam takes 20 seconds
man okay what's what involve simple
enough you you you you you testify to
the one there's no pool there's no
baptism like I I often joke with people
I'm like all right we got the pool in
the back we're going to do the baptism
now um you know uh it's it's literally
um testifying to the Oneness of God and
test ifying that Muhammad uh is his
final messenger and so that's called the
shahada and when you testify to the
Oneness of God and to uh the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him being his
final Prophet you are accepting what's
known as the six articles of Faith six
articles of Faith are belief in one God
belief in the Angels belief in The
Messengers so you can't be a Muslim
without believing in Jesus or Moses or
Abraham or Muhammad um to believe in the
message messages that God has spoken to
humanity uh through divine revelation
the Quran being the the last uh
Revelation to believe in the day of
judgment and to believe in Divine decree
and predestination so those are six
articles of Faith so when you testify um
to the Oneness of God and to the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him being the
final messenger that's called the
shahada you embrace the package of those
articles of Faith that's the implication
then you learn the prayers learn to fast
in Ramadan um you give what's known as
zaka the mandatory charity 2.5% of your
retained earnings and uh Hajj which is
the pilgrimage to Mecca if you can so
that's the growth part the journey um
you know once a person takes the
testimony they then grow uh it's really
interesting because we always have uh
those people that convert to Islam like
a week before Ramadan or even a day
before Ramadan so uh you're Muslim and
you got to fast the next day uh you know
and that's always a challenging
experience for people but a fulfilling
experience for many people um when they
Embrace Islam at that point and again I
mean it's
it's it's it's simple and I think that
the beauty of Islam to many people is in
its Simplicity one God one Humanity one
body of prophets um and uh one
community